he's the MLB Network analyst Fox MLB
analyst he's does a tremendous job for
everyone that he works for
he's the baseball / if you will the best
/ since Deion Sanders he's Tom Verducci
how are you Tom
Goodrich I've gotta know though I'm so
impressed with your kids wrote to you
from Camp yes if they do that on their
own or was that like a camp assignment
it's a clamp assignment every day they
have to sit down and write and also
here's another great thing about the
camp Tom great a great thing
no screen time no iPads no phones no
nothing it's like oh sit down and write
you want to communicate what how about
that oh my gosh how do you have kids Tom
I do they're no longer in camp they're
grown they're grown CMS baseball yeah
that's great yeah oh gosh so all right
let's let's uh let's get into it here
trade deadline is approaching what are
you hearing what you know obviously the
biggest the biggest name in Machado went
and then Brad hand went also what are we
looking at right here with familia also
having been moved yeah and those teams
are stepping up early I the next big one
I think is act Britain you know he's had
eight scoreless outings recently and I
think people now are not as concerned as
they were early on if he was all the way
back from that Achilles a big time
demand here I think he's probably going
it you know can't go to the Dodgers
because I think that may push them over
the tax threshold unless they somehow
move other money but you know Euston the
Yankees Diamondbacks the Red Sox the
mean let's face it the trade deadline
for me is mostly about relief pitching I
love what Cleveland did not just with
hand but with Cimber as well so to me
Britain is the next big piece and again
I think because it's a it's a really
strong market I don't think you'll have
to wait till the 31st I think it's just
a matter of days before he winds up for
a postseason contender well I mean it's
is the price higher for the Yankees and
the Red Sox because of location because
of the division Tom
I don't think so the Orioles are a very
weird team to kind of try to read and we
saw that throughout the Machado
negotiation listen I think they'll make
the best deal especially if since
Britain is just a pure rental as if
they're gonna have to look at Britain
pitching for the Yankees of Red Sox for
the next 3-4 years so I think it's about
the best deal and it would shock me if
it's one of those teams in the East but
I do think Houston has I think the
biggest need I mean they can always put
McCullers in the bullpen to close in the
postseason but they don't really don't
have a left-handed guy anyway and I
think they'd feel a lot better it's
funny rich they're both and their
numbers are great but they're still
uncertainty about the last three out of
a game in October and I think Britain
would answer that not to kick the
Orioles when they're down bought 2873
Tom I mean and Buck is we all know he
hasn't forgotten how to manage I mean
how how did this come about and what in
the world do they do do they just
totally figuratively burn it down and
build it back up again what's going on
well I mean it's not just Britain we've
already seen Machado go Adam Jones the
last year of his field bread bracha last
year of his deal unfortunately for the
Orioles they still have Chris Davis for
many more years and that's probably you
know the biggest domino that film you
know they made the huge investment in
Chris Davis coming off a big year and
you know between the shift and between a
guy who always had a ton of swing and
miss in his game that contract and Chris
Davis himself was just killing them I
mean it's really one of the worst
position seasons ever in Major League
Baseball and it's a guy that you're
paying to be an impact hitter and also
the Oriole is just have invested no
money in international scouting I mean
zero money it's you know it's something
that I know how they do in today's game
but they do they just don't spend money
on the international market and that's
coming back to burn them so I know the
whole you know tear it down to build it
up thing is fashionable these days in
baseball but they're build up to me
based on what they have right now in
their system is it will take a very long
time and that's why this trade
huge for that and [ __ ] in his last
deal Dan Duquette last year of his deal
a good luck predicting the future you
know two three even one year out for the
Baltimore Orioles right now mmm
Tom Verducci here on the Rich Eisen show
MLB Network and Fox MLB analyst here I
was I said to myself I will not bring up
the shift but you mentioned it so now I
have I mean so since we last spoke
we're here in your awesome broadcast of
the all-star game Lindor being asked by
John Smoltz about his athleticism and
how the shift affects it as a shortstop
and then he talks about how it takes
hits away flat-out set it and then we
see Matt Carpenter on one of the great
all-time tears break up a an extra-base
hit hitting streak by bunting down the
left-field line because he's against a
shift and I'm wondering like what are we
trying to achieve here Tom with this
thing right well I think if the object
is to achieve a game that is most
attractive to the most people then we
have to do something about the shift I
get the argument that listen you'd be
stifling innovation in some sort of way
by putting any kind of governor or ban a
shift because let's face it it's making
great use of data that we have in the
game it does take its away especially to
left-handed hitters rich I'd look at the
batting average versus left-handed
hitters right-handed hitters with shifts
without shifts it's all pretty much in a
small window in the two 40s to 50s until
you get to Landers facing shifts and
they hit to 27 to 27 and the reason is
obviously as a pull hitter lefty the
defense of that side can flex farther
back and cover more ground and it also
takes hips away not just the pull field
but up the middle so I believe we have
to do something because if you just hear
you say hey listen these guys should be
able to adapt baseball Edd's and flows
we know it by the time baseball starts
to flow after all this ending if you've
watched the generation of fans you don't
see enough hits this is a few
with his in a game since the th started
in 1973 it's not a good look and I get
what people say listen bus it's hit the
ball the other way
well what a babe ruin foreplay today
right first of all think he'd be very
good he'd be pretty old but if he were
playing today they would shift up Babe
Ruth there's no doubt in my mind about
that he would not hit 383 and people
would probably tell Babe Ruth hey why
don't you just drop a bug fixes you know
choked up hit the ball the other way is
that really what we want
that was what left-handed hitters to do
I listen I think a few should bunt once
in a while but I really believe we need
some governor's on the ship even if it's
for me a rule that says the infielders
have to have one foot on the dirt that
way you can flex over you have three
guys in the right hand side but you're
not playing that rover position a
softball position in the outfield me
rich you know in the NFL you always put
your thumb on the scale balancing
offense and defense right yes you can't
beat up the wide receiver you know after
five yards NBA we have illegal defenses
it's not an outrageous idea to put some
sort of Governor on defenses in MLB
that's exactly what I say whenever I
discuss it on the show or put it out
there on Twitter or when folks are like
well you can't tell Bella check where to
put his defenders and I'm like well yes
you can they have to be five yards
removed from the offensive line in terms
of touching somebody I mean you can have
them right up within the five yards but
you can't hit your opponent within a
five yard rule and and and that made the
game better and Plus baseball's the only
sport where the defense already has the
ball they're in the possession of the
ball that's the only sport and so I
think people have to realize that you
know doing nothing here to me is not an
option anymore because the trend line
here for the last ten years and
especially the last five years is that
were giving people fewer balls in play
over a longer period of time that is the
worst possible formula for any kind of
industry that wants to attract people
with they're basically to pre time so I
think something has to be done to move
this along because the trend lines to me
with more strikeouts and fewer hits year
year after year is not going to it's not
going to turn quickly and as I said by
the time it does turn we've lost a lot
more fans certainly since Tom there's
been you know an influx of young players
who are very very good at this sport I
mean Pedro was talking about it the
other day
about how he loves the new generation
and then I mean of all the names of a
young kid to shine out with a great
story ponce de Lyonne last night I mean
that's you can't you can't copyright
that yourself Tom what a great story
what a great story you know especially
that obviously the injury that he had
getting hit in the head and you know
he's a 27 year old guy he's been to four
different colleges late round draft pick
it's a fantastic story and for pitching
seven no-hit innings he's going to get
sent down to the minor leagues it's
basically just a paperwork move because
they need another starter in the
meantime he'll be back and he'll have a
lot more fans rooting for him it's the
great thing about baseball I'm sure it
happens in other sports too but there's
so many late-round stories or non
drafted stories and guys make it to the
big leagues they're easier for and
that's certainly one of them last one
for you it's the a happy pint our 35th
anniversary Tom yeah you know what I we
actually covered the resumption of the
pipes our game on August 18th and there
were about I don't know 2,000 people
there at Yankee Stadium Ron Guidry
played centerfield Don Mattingly played
second base yeah we had gone on last
hour Tom to recall that and how Billy
Martin put him out there at second he
said he didn't remember why it you know
because Billy was protesting but also
just in terms of the players that he
already had on the roster right wasn't
that the reason why they put him out
there yes exactly right he wasn't happy
about having you know Lee MacPhail had
overturned the ruling so he wasn't happy
to be playing that resumption anyway but
yeah and by the way I know you know this
Mattingly is an unbelievable athlete he
used to take ground balls at shortstop
right-handed for the Yankees and you
could not tell that he was left-handed
it was amazing great high school
basketball player great guys well the
great athlete and by the way did you
know that bats that George Brett used
yes the model
of the bet was a Marv's Throneberry bet
marvelous Marv Throneberry are you
certain less Marv from Barry yes and
that's the one that Gaylord Perry
snatched and ran up the up the clubhouse
tunnel with I know I mean and in then on
the resumption of that day and Don was
talking about a to last hour that the
umpires were different on the day of the
resumption and Major League Baseball in
the American League office knew that the
Yankees were gonna try and do some sort
of shenanigans to try and see if Brett
touched every base and protests the game
because the umpires were different how
would they know whether Brett touched
every base they had all the umpires from
that day sign an affidavit testifying
that Brett touched every base and Dave
is it true Dave Phillips popped out the
paperwork on exactly right you got this
nailed rich yeah it was David Phillips
and listen when you're dealing with
Billy Martin right you have to be aware
for all tricks in the book and they
weren't they totally had him and Billy
thought he had a great argument that he
was going to appeal that Brett didn't
touch all the bases and they were ready
for you talk about some of the rogues in
the game how perfect is that that Billy
Martin is managing the Yankees trying to
appeal a play from two months earlier
right on the other side you had Gaylord
Perry you talking about a rogue
character absconded with the bottom
George Brett beautiful stuff 35 years
see more roads like that in the game
today the guys today tonight this is
more over just get him out there right
and start stealing bats and put pine tar
on my gosh 35 years later who are you
working for on that day Tom who was
working for a Newton for Newsday in New
York yeah I my assignment that day was
the right of sidebar to talk to some of
the people I actually could have talked
to all of them
it was so empty but like why would you
come and watch basically four outs and
they talked to what I talked to one guy
who brought his child who is like one
year old he said I wanted this to be his
first game okay and that kid is now 35
years old
next month alright tom thanks for the
time you got any time thank you god it's
Tom Verducci the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience